Oo!! we're about to go
Nice cheery music, 10/10
some1 offscreen: "Alright guys, let's make like a baby and head out."
Take off!
this seems fun, I like this
thUd
oof
back to some lovely facial expressions from our boi
[Laughter from woman]
Oo, some shakey shake
[Shaking noises from ATV]
he doesn't look that comfortable
you ok Mark?
blink blonk
confusion
man, the view we have out of this ATV is astonishing
[More shaking noises]
omg more shakes!!
what's shakin', baby? ;)
[Shaking continues]
shake shake shake senora
shake it left and right
violentshaKES
sh
shsh
shshsh
shshshsh
shshshshsh
shshshshshake
shshshshshakee
i am shook
you are shook
we all be shooketh
(me after voltron season 7 amiright)
poor markimoo
RIP, cause of death: the shakes
Mark looks even more shooketh
we all relate fam
did Mark enjoy this experience?
I don't think so
probably not
to be fair, there IS happy music in the background
[Indistinct speaking]
So he must of had a good time??
hahaha, look at his face
thwOOSH
keep looking at his face :)
relief
y i k e s
Ah man, the constant electrical humming in the background is lovely as well
duck face
This is a religious experience
s h o o k e t h
This looks like a pure never ending, constant stream of pain (Also kudos to whoever paused the video to read this)
he looks really sad :( also where music go???
[Cheerful music stops]
music back!!!
and more shakeyshakey
shake that thang ;)
werk
~wooshing wind~
uhhhh
what's a synonym for shake? [jolt?]
:O
:o
well there's no need to look up a synonym [i just said jolt...]
[Woman giggles]
why? 1) im lazy 2) the ride is coming to an end :(
[Indistinct speaking]
* unbuckle *
wow a different angle of mark's face!!!!
wow the open air!!
omg hes turning the camera everybody!!1!
thumbs up
radical dude (also pretty view!)
Bye!!
also i will defend these captions for life -non